thank you
first time we met Stefan Diggs in person
that was at the Minneapolis Super Bowl
and we had a lot of fun with him we've
stayed in touch with him obviously is
now with the Buffalo Bills and the wide
receiver joining us on behalf of Downey
unstoppables you know if you're going to
represent Downy you better look clean
let's say a load of stuff on Diggs who
joins us on the program
[Applause]
yeah you want to pull the microphone up
there to you yeah all right
we had that awkward moment where he went
to shake my hand I went to get him dab
and then then I had it's a little early
yesterday what is policy though with do
you start with dap or do you start with
hands I start with uh dab typically just
because you never know how clean
people's hands are number but but if I
like y'all Mike oh I might okay but you
gave me it I kind of forced the
handshake when I met you earlier today
so we're half and half all right I just
want to make sure I do like you I don't
want to get you I don't want to get
called for encroachment I just want to
make sure which is colder Minnesota or
Buffalo
uh it's Minnesota still uh Buffalo gets
a lot more snow but Minnesota I'll never
forget just because my first year I was
outside and you know M T Bank Stadium it
was fun but it was damn sure cold but
but don't you think that'd be a great
home field advantage if in Minnesota to
have outs Outdoors well I had uh Buffalo
it's all it's been you know we've had
inclement weather like past couple years
so it's like we do have Advantage when
guys come in and it's cold and you know
when Miami comes or somebody like that
that doesn't play in the coast a little
bit of Advantage but should we factor in
where you play and what weather you play
in when we look at your stats when your
career is all over 100 I mean I feel
like if we had a nice indoor I think
we're working on something right now uh
you know to be a little different but we
we're out there making it work you know
the other team is just as slow so how
long is it going to take to build that
new stadium
I'm no Stadium expert or maybe maybe a
year and a half
nobody talked to you about the stadium I
think that's above my opinion oh okay
but you could be curious I want to ask
more questions but then I gotta you know
good things come to those who wait right
okay but how long's your contract for I
think I got a couple years okay I just
don't want them to get the Stadium
completed and I'm long then you're gone
then you're in Miami or something
is is Debo Samuel if we lined up all the
receivers everybody in the NFL who's
winning 100 meter dash
is that a real question yeah I mean
Tyreek here like it's not even it's not
even a question yeah it's not that like
he's uh he's a rose he's a real special
talent he got a different kind of speed
so I mean and it's a lot of fast guys in
the league when it's a lot of fast guys
you still got to look at a guy like
who's really separating at a high level
okay who's the second fastest guy in the
NFL
his counterparts
I mean he's in a mix and I I like Turpin
too from the Cowboys yeah he plays more
like Return Man but he's extremely fast
could you put together a four by 100
relay team and maybe metal in the
Olympics nah nah no because the track is
just a different real speed out there I
feel like the guys that are in the
league they're fast and I'm I'm behind
him 100 but uh that track speed is
different wait you don't think Tyree now
I tried to set up Tyreke versus Usain
Bolt yeah
and and I thought if I did 60 or 70
meters Tyreke could take Usain Bolt I
agree with that not a hundred I agree
with that because once you sing gets
those long legs going then he's gone I
liked Harry Connors takes me though
right so you think he he yeah yeah he
only separated towards it back and he
beat Everybody by what 10 meters I guess
yeah those legs get to turn and it's
kind of hard to you know stop but Tyree
could probably do that to defensive
backs yeah that's your guy yeah I like
it all right
um Justin Jefferson got offensive player
of the year yeah are you okay with that
he deserved it okay I washed some
clothes he had a great year especially
from the receiver position I also feel
like uh you know coming from you know
pull that a little closer to coming from
an offensive driven team like uh their
head coach was an offensive guy you know
that plays a huge part in like offensive
scheme and what they're doing so but no
competition like between wide receivers
it's tough I mean he was he was he was
getting a lot of targets too and you
know only people that were really touch
the ball as much as him was the
quarterback so I mean I feel like he
deserved it 100 percent
could you feel like uh America was
rooting for you guys this year oh man
100 from the beginning of the year uh
even from the previous year I feel like
everybody went into with the right
mindset of just like man this year
Buffalo should win it and do what
they're supposed to do so and then with
everything that happened like the trials
and tribulations we had a ton of
injuries we had things happen at the end
of the year I feel like uh it's like
that feel good story that you want so
bad everybody wants that feel good story
but sorry but you know we live in the
real world too well it was like a Disney
movie it just didn't have a Disney
ending yeah it's like more so like a
nightmare Maybe
I had the feeling that last game you
walk off the field it was just
disappointing um damn damn sure
frustrated you know everybody really put
in a grand scheme of things of uh how
long a year is you know and our year was
damn sure I mean it just felt that much
longer with everything we had to go
through and endure so uh just utter
disappointment frustrated and it was
like well [__] we did all this for this
and it seemed just like seemed like a
little bit not real like when we lost
and I was just like really like uh
trying to let it register that like damn
that's what we just did out there so it
was it was damn sure frustrating and
disappointing yeah and I understand your
frustration yeah and everything's on
camera yeah so we see you and and Josh
on the sidelines but I'd rather that you
know you had passion there then that it
didn't bother you I know that you know
you've probably been asked about it
looked at it talked to Josh about it
yeah but what looking back on it what
should we know about that moment where
you two where you had words with him
well looking back
um it was it was just it was just a you
know that season that kind of like shook
out the way it did I feel like the first
nine weeks we had a we had a kind of
like a formula like a recipe for winning
and
uh we kind of got away from it on the
back end you know I'm saying we were we
were creating creating ways to win but
and just how we were winning wasn't as
smooth as the first nine weeks so uh and
I kind of tested that just throughout
the season you know we had a lot of ups
and downs and um individually just
trying to keep them things keep things
tied together it's just it was just some
crucial moments in the in the year that
uh like late in the late in this late in
the season you know late in the fourth
quarter it was opportunities and we
didn't take advantage of
so I feel like um like that last that
last uh I guess series or that last play
when you saw frustration it wasn't
necessarily just that play but those
moments built up to it like culmination
it's exactly it's it's and for me it was
uh up to this point like we've seen
quarterback and receivers as far as like
tandems and guys who play at a high
level and every quarterback has their
guy you know in those moments like you
you are the guy you're standing up to
this point I've been a guy uh for my
team for my quarterback so in those
moments of course I want the ball I'm
saying I'm never apologize for that I
I'll show you a good loser I'll show you
a loser you know what I'm saying at the
end of the day um like in that moment uh
it was fourth and whatever of course I
was one-on-one on the backside and I
wanted to put us in a position to win so
um you know I'll never apologize for
passion because we kind of we forget
about this game I guess like and you
know some people say like oh don't be a
sore loser or you know it's hard not to
be frustrated so for me I always look at
it as
earlier in that season we had a um we
had a real scare you know we had
something that you know we never thought
we'll see 99.9 the thing but Demar I'm
saying so it kind of like put things in
perspective for a lot of people and it
came became real that slim change became
real for everybody we saw it so it kind
of seemed like uh we forget how much uh
we're putting into this game until
moments like that happen and so when
this moment like would we lose and
people try to tell you to have be a good
sport or you know Pat you on the back
like this isn't Little League Baseball
nothing against Little League Baseball
so I was just like uh I just want people
to really be reminded of how serious
this game is and how much you know
people are putting into each and every
day I train year round for 17 weeks or
20 weeks so uh in a moment of
frustration I just always want that to
be like in the Forefront and you said
Stefan Diggs the Buffalo Bills wide
receiver when Demar goes down yeah I
mean the game is so fast then everything
slows down yeah and that everything
stops and it's a weird reaction because
you're not used to anything like nothing
slows down in the NFL
and now all of a sudden you see your
teammate on the ground like what's the
first thing you're thinking I just got
kind of like a little bit of chills
right now or maybe just because it's
cold I'm not sure but
um I remember vividly it kind of
happened right in front of my face
because typically sometimes I get off
the bench to support the defense so I'm
looking and the way it kind of happened
so fast he failed and the guys that were
behind me like I thought somebody pushed
him and he just like you know like you
flop or you go on the ground but then he
didn't move so it was it was just a
moment of just like I don't know like um
like the world stopped like it's perfect
for you when you say the world stop you
could damn the hair pin drop in the
stadium it's just like because somebody
everybody knew something was wrong it
wasn't as simple as like uh he didn't
get up or he had a concussion so
um I tell you now when our teammates
kind of rallied around him and got into
a circle it was more so to try to
protect them so people couldn't see but
the fact that the people that could see
really saw I'm saying so when you were
up close and personal with it something
that we I don't wish on anybody I'm
saying but what are you seeing when
you're looking at him well like At first
like uh when I saw him I'm sorry it's
been a little bit be a little graphic
but it was like some blood coming from
his mouth and it was like I was like it
seemed like somebody hit him or
something like that I was like nah like
something wrong so uh when the medical
staff shout out to the medical staff
um they rushed over there it seemed like
they knew something was going on so we
rallied behind them and kind of like
circled up and you saw you saw him
low-key go come back go come back and
um something I'd
I mean you obviously I've had experience
with life and death uh I've seen death
like but it's just like for your
teammate and it just happened so fast on
a football field it's like this it's
like damn what the hell is going on like
somebody helped somebody helping it's
like uh you just want to see something
good happen and it was it happened and
it didn't and it happened and finally
um things kind of like a little bit turn
the corner and then you know football
was just in the Air Force seconds like
this damn like we forgot all about
football for a second what was it like
first time you saw him afterwards oh uh
well I saw him in a hospital was he all
hooked up to yeah it was it was a scary
sight uh I'm not big on hospitals and
that's just a personal thing because
last time I seen somebody in the
hospital was my father and I kind of saw
him in a similar state so when I saw him
out it was it was real triggering but
um it was like some some life I'm hoping
to be like all right he's at least
manageable right now or trying to get to
be manageable so but when he came back
to the facility oh yeah it was like a
breath of fresh air like uh I don't know
it's like I don't know how many cookouts
you've been to how many cookouts have
you been to have you been in any cookout
well Marvin is inviting me too okay
stuff on the playlist that you have so I
usually do a playlist on like Fridays
because I was saying like look when you
go to a cookout the music is so
important yes right so you play that uh
Frankie Beverly and Maze Before I Let Go
yeah never too much yeah I told you it's
the Black version of don't stop
believin'
[Laughter]
so this is what it's like uh when you're
invited to the cookout you go to the
sorry I'm sitting the stage but when you
go to the cookout you might see an old
cousin that you haven't seen in some
years yeah it's like like cousin like so
nice to see you so that's what it that's
what kind of but could you hug like were
you nervous about hugging tomorrow not
cause he was moving around so I was like
I figured like I mean I wasn't going to
squeeze him
[Music]
fair enough fair enough uh tell us what
you're doing with Downey oh I'm here on
on behalf of Downey uh unstoppables uh
I'm all about looking clean and fresh no
you look good come on yeah you look good
one of my suits I had in my closet so
I'm all about and smelling fresh I like
to smell good so it's like perfume for
your clothes it just all right it
doesn't clean your clothes let me be
clear about that but it will have you
smelling fresh no is does your shirt
have digs on the collar nah that's Dior
oh Dior
I
don't know
my bad I said hey you might get one of
those at the cookout though
okay Dior you got to get digs I know I
know I'm not that cool yet you're not
who could do that in the NFL you could
do it well I could but I'm not in the
NFL like could Mahomes do it
please oh no that's his swag
he's like Joe burrow could do it Joe Joe
cool I'll give it 100
are you okay are you okay with Joe's
outfits that he wears yeah I love I love
his swag I love his Swag like literally
he comes in there he walks in the
stadium how
if I was a quarterback I would want to
walk in the stadium you know he Joe cool
you got to be a a damn good quarterback
if you're a white guy coming in with
stuff like that well I actually I heard
you played a little quarterback a little
bit Yeah high school high school yeah
all right what made you switch over you
didn't I didn't like when they hit me
again you get to red jerseys
and I'm not Josh Allen I I don't take
contact like that I get it uh all right
so Downing unstoppables and uh let's see
uh partner with a mystery celebrity
hidden under a sweatshirt Washington
Downey Unstoppable yeah to be revealed
during the Super Bowl
okay soon come I actually brought you
something too what are you doing
can't be as cool as though
do you have me oh you gotta cause you're
my good friend now I got a chain here
you're invited to the cookout you gotta
have something to wear today okay I
don't I don't know if I can wear this to
the cookout Donnie Patrick
Dan you're one chains
[Applause]
is coming to the cookout he's ready if I
walk into the cookout like this
they're gonna love you they're gonna say
okay I see you I see you with your ice
pimping ain't easy yeah
what's up home slice
uh hey thank you for you know joining us
during the year and you know I know it
didn't end well but you're always one of
our favorite guests you're uh you're
just a fun person thank you so much I
appreciate you guys so it's Downy
unstoppables he's Stefan Diggs the 12
weeks of freshness we'll take a break
our play of the day is up next